the body administration just can't help
but use the ukraine refugee crisis to
push their liberal green agenda climate
czar john kerry making this outrageous
comment
if you think migration has been a
problem in europe in the syrian war or
even from what we see now
when you see 100 million people for whom
the entire
food production capacity has collapsed
greg
i love this talking canoe paddle
because he's a great reminder of like
the problem of having a single
ideological filter so he sees everything
through the filter of climate and he
comes off as a buffoon because he
applies it in non-climate issues so he
just inserts it everywhere and you see
modern academics do that with except
their filter is america as an oppressor
cnn for seven years their filter was
race and what did that do it created
tribalism and no ratings so it's really
bad
it's the best advice for somebody who
wants to be successful in life is to
have a number of filters that you can
use i tend to see everything through the
prism of media persuasion which at times
is amazing but other times you know
makes me an insensitive jerk that's the
president you said it we didn't
but i admit it all right i thought there
was another prism in there somewhere
well there's there is one there is one
it's disgusting dana what are your
thoughts on the human uh that one really
well i think you know secretary kerry um
well he's also now he's the climate czar
which is a little weird right like
please let's drop the czar term at the
white house um he's very mission focused
and that's all he's going to talk about
but think about he was the secretary of
state he had all the issues and he could
be the person that they helped bring in
to like make something happen like
something creative and instead he's
talking about this food prices are going
to go up because no food can be grown or
get out of the bread basket of the world
in ukraine and russia and there will be
uprisings and it won't necessarily just
be because of climate change because of
the cost of food like what happened in
egypt in 2008. yeah it's going to get
crazy in the middle east with the wheat
geraldo but it is true jesse that
millions of people have been uprooted by
this and millions more will be uh you
have entire populations on the move this
is the biggest refugee crisis dwarfing
afghanistan and syria in europe wait
until all these people start going west
into these other countries at what point
can poland uh will poland say enough
basta i can't handle what was it
pasta
yeah when are we to start taking these
refugees in uh i can't wait i oh the
vice president basically whiffed well
but you know what it it it seems we're
taking everybody else in i mean we could
either bring him in through the mexican
border or you know we should get elected
these are freedom fighters these are
people who believe in the same things
that we believe in i mean their families
are staying back to fight for freedom
and for their country they believe in
ukraine they believe in their mission we
want them here do you think biden's
worried that the ukrainian refugees
might vote republican yeah kind of like
the cuban refugees remember we met with
mayor i don't know what he believes but
i'm shocked that he hasn't invited more
of him here that's a good angle biden
doesn't want ukrainian refugees because
they'll vote republican i just wrote
your headline
that wasn't my idea by the way
sounded like it was no it wasn't it's
fun at first i hate you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else